derrière ses grilles de plusieurs mètres
d'eau situé chemin de bellevue et à
louveciennes se cache la maison la plus
chère du monde
bâti sur le modèle du château de
vaux-le-vicomte la demeure privée
construite en 2011 a été vendu 275
millions d'euros
l'acheteur bénéficie de 23 hectares de
terrain et d'un château moderne de 5000
mètres carrés équipée d'une salle de
cinéma de mobilier du xviie siècle et de
plusieurs piscines
c'était une alliance en quelque sorte
des techniques de construction moderne
en utilisant notamment le béton armé sur
lequel ont été recouverts ont été placés
les pierres qui étaient issues de
carrières qui étaient les mêmes que
celles qu'on avait utilisé pour des
châteaux prestigieux comme évidemment le
château de versailles
dans la ville les 7200 habitants sont
partagés sur cette acquisition va je
suis dans la science fiction là quand
vous me parlez de ce château etc
donc c'est difficile de sortir des mots
et de s'exprimer à ce sujet là vous
pouvez prendre n'importe quelle douce et
moi je crois qu'ils sont ils sont comme
moi sont dans le même état quoi voilà on
est plus plus terre à terre il ya
d'autres choses qui me font rêver mois
d'autres choses qui me font rêver sans
avoir autant de voix de châteaurenaud un
bungalow ça me fait rêver vous voyez je
pense que ça a été un bon coup
médiatique pour faire valoriser le
village on a connu au niveau national
loup sienne qui est un joli petit
village de son côté la vie ne touchera
pas de pactole suite à cette vente la
transaction se fait uniquement avec des
sociétés civiles immobilières les
propriétés payeront seulement la taxe
d'habitation sera était un bol d'air
pour notre commune de recevoir un droit
de mutation quand même très conséquents
puisque on avait calculé qui dépassaient
le million d'euros l'identité du
propriétaire est toujours tenue secrète
selon les proches du dossier il
s'agirait d'un particulier originaire du
moyen-orient
l'acheteur n'aurait toujours pas posé sa
valise dans son château moderne de
louveciennes depuis son acquisition